love that and I love that you can't if
I'm doing Peter Parker I love that you
can't see me that you see them yeah I
think that's such a great part of odd
feeling though knowing it's your voice
coming out of something that little kids
are just like oh my God but what's
really nice and what gets really trippy
and it's probably just because I've
smoked so much weed that I'm already
stoned as from just the
air is that it's not me anymore I record
it in the booth but it's not me when you
watch it that's Peter B Parker if it's
my body it's too close to me that I have
to say like you know when people say
like how much are you like Nick Miller
from New Girl and I'm like well it's
hard because we improvised guy
looks like me I'm talking a lot there's
a lot of connection what's great about
voiceover is you go like no artists
created all this they wrote it out they
wrote it out they animated it they
created every movement I just put 15%
into is it the best job in Hollywood
basically being a voiceover actor I
really love it yeah you